manny pacquiao running for president can
he win
what do what you're going to think like
next thing you're going to tell me like
a reality starting to be president
or something it's crazy he's running for
president 2022 i'm a fighter and i will
always be a fighter inside and outside
the ring we need government to serve our
people with integrity compassion and
transparency
the crescent current president rodrigo
duterte
has led a brutal campaign against
illegal drugs and said last week he
would rather die first before facing an
international tribunal a tribunal
the day after the international criminal
court announced it would investigate
allegations of crimes against humanity
linked to the crackdown that has left
thousands dead can you imagine pacquiao
becomes a
president i mean he's got to be the most
popular guy there right he's been he's
been congressman you've got a
congressman there for a long time i
wouldn't be surprised at all he's not i
don't think he's going to be the only uh
fighter that's that's uh president of
the country apparently uh i believe it's
vladimir klitschko one of the klitschko
brothers is being positioned uh for a
run at the ukraine uh as well so
hey look man um
i i don't know enough about filipino
politics to to comment on it but he's
about i was waiting to get your level of
expectations
you know but i'm sorry i you know i used
to know tagalog but i just i i yeah but
i would say this though like one of the
things about the future right is it goes
all the way back to what you said before
brand first right like brand first manny
pacquiao's brand is incredibly strong
he's known as a person of integrity he's
known as somebody that that you know it
cares about the community and pat you
talk about a synergist right like he's
not a catalyst he's not somebody that's
gonna turn one side against the other as
far as i know so you know maybe this is
the future we're laughing about it now
but maybe the future is
popular people who care about their own
their own brand so they're not going to
do something crazy and out of character
that can bring the two powerful sides
together maybe maybe instead of fighting
this and looking at you know pat talking
about how jake paul is going to be
president and aoc is going to be present
logan i'm sorry we've got to embrace
the reality of the situation being that
hey look man this is the quote-unquote
new normal and maybe there's a good
thing that can come out of this maybe
there's synergy to be had by people that
are universally liked being in positions
of power
i think you know it's been proven since
reagan right i mean you got a guy like
reagan who goes from being a sag
president to
being the the spokesperson for ge and
they were paying him 750 to a million
years to go around talking about how
great ge is to
him uh uh doing hollywood and then
becomes a governor you know and then
becomes president likability
well
i don't know man because likability
isn't really a useful
a useful trait in a leader right like
you have to be disagreeable i think it's
a useful trait to be likable i mean
you know george bush junior everybody
wants to have a beer who do you want to
have a beer with george bush you know
yeah i can see i can see why people vote
for likeable people you know but i don't
know a leader being good being in a
position of leadership you guys both run
sometimes
you can't be it's like
everybody trust you want to be in
business with you right people gotta
like you yeah people because think about
it this way what's more important like
or trust which comes first like or trust
i gotta like you to trust there you go
so so before you could be the most
trusting human being in the world but no
one likes you because your first
impression sucks i'm sorry we're never
going to find that the juice you offer
which is trust totally yeah so
likability is extremely important
business this is one of my problems with
robert green really really smart guy and
i and i i love his work but like 48
rules of power that there should have
been a caveat at the beginning that's
like unless you know how to be
charismatic this is just 48 ways to be a
jerk like unless you can be charismatic
did you like the book or no why don't
you like the book because it's too dark
yes it's like uh
how to achieve um in a very negative way
right it's that you don't have to follow
those rules you don't have to do it that
way it's kind of like a manipulative
guide to manipulation and winning
through uh power and i just didn't like
it i mean i read it but and i thought
some of it was true for sure but i don't
think that i certainly won't give my son
asher that book and be like you read
this this is the rules to like the rules
to life like jordan you know read this
as a rules to power i wouldn't because i
wouldn't want him to live his life that
way you know what his reasoning was to
write the book he said he wrote it for
you to know how those people run to go
against them not necessarily for you to
be like that but for it was kind of a
guide i agree with you but he said that
but i agree with you have you read his
other books he wrote a book uh uh art of
seduction i don't know if you've read it
it's a ridiculous book it's it's an
incredible book art of seduction then
you got 33 strategies awards my favorite
out of all of them 33 strategies award
law number four is insane you got a big
shout out from andy young about the
power uh um
uh
about um
what was it paranoid uh
only the paranoid survival he said it
was in the growth yeah he said it was
the best book he ever read
it's it's a ridiculous book andy grove
is a
legend so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you